ah hey karen what are you doing oh just
said
stanley walker is a dirty
pig i'm good how are you
guys problem with stan i can't believe
him
parading around town with that new
british of his
yeah last week they had dinner at the
mayor's mansion
apparently she spent the entire night
sitting on his lap feeding him steaks
here's a nice t-bone for your love hope
you save room for a bucket of potatoes
oh i regret the day i ever laid boobs on
that man
i'm not supposed to tell you this but
will's been sleeping with him hi i knew
there was something i wasn't supposed to
tell you grace is sleeping with jackson
boudreau
and her doorman
wait a minute are you telling me that
will and grace are eskimo sisters
honey i have no idea what that means but
that is exactly what i am saying
honey
wait a minute
do you not hear what i don't hear
i think i don't care the song's gone
maybe the idea of will and grace being
one penis away from actually having sex
with each other cured it
you're right and good for grace you know
she's one step closer to her ultimate
goal
yes it is i
i would like to spend time with you
so
not my type
[Applause]
okay guys are you ready
okay on the count of three one what's up
with this two really guys
that was fun
i'm glad i put a bow on it was a more
festive message
oh hey we got a nibble some loser across
the way spending christmas in his
bathtubs checking us out
hey look he's hot and he's waving
come on let's put up our stockings
before sanny gets here
what
i made it myself
my home teacher said i was a needlepoint
prodigy in fact i was the only guy to
have a piece in the statewide
needlepoint competition
well
the only guy who's still a guy
[Laughter]
hey you're not santa claus
close though he got a couple of white
hair sprouting on your chin you look
like you just came down the chimney
mrs walker
cheryl bricker fosberg taylor and
hayden's mom
i have no idea what you just said
i just want you to know i think you're
awful
your son mason swam his heart out today
and all he wanted to do was share that
joy with his family but when he looked
up in the bleachers for a familiar face
nothing not even a housekeeper
i find that appalling
oh yeah well i find stretch pants
appalling but i'm too much of a lady to
mention it fat ass
and now
i must pack my beards
but which beard shall i bring with me
not this one
our carriage shall arrive at anything
with
we can stop and go antiquing which will
probably be a lot cheaper because
everything's new
nay mary todd
you cannot have come now back to
bed yeah and who's paying for it in fact
who's paying for your whole p-town
sausage party
why it's me mary todd i'm paying for
everything
mary todd
it's just that shouldn't we have
everything
anastasia beaverhouse
anastasia like russian royalty
beaverhouse unlike
where the beaver live
[Laughter]
dynamite
what brings you to this lush paradise
miss beaver
oh
i don't know really just
killing time i suppose
waiting for something good to happen
interesting
i was just doing the same thing
looks like my weight is over
well well
where did you come from lionel did the
smooth-talking gigolo convention let out
early
listen why don't we
continue this in my very comfortable
suite upstairs
i've got loads of cash so time is no
issue
mr banks you think i'm a hooker
body those claws that voice
yes
well
as flattered as i am by that i'm afraid
i have to disappoint you
you don't have sex for money no i do not
or jewels for furs for mixed securities
like a lady
but for money how dare you
and one
and two and to the side three good and
four once again and one very good and
two and three
and
um four yes four
right and spin very good and very good
one
jack
this is so much fun i can't wait to try
this with a man
but i am a man oh look you are
okay well that was very good you got the
basics down let's move on let's try a
little something new check this out
ready for this and kick it and kick it
and take it very good very nice now
let's get a little dirty let's move in
we're getting dirty nice
[Applause]
now kiss
hey me check this out
[Music]
[Laughter]
oh
kurt
have you been working out
wait you're not cursed you're not hurt
either now look what you've done me you
scared him off with your big boobies and
your weird bisexual vibe
you're an oddly confident 40 year old
secretary
this is the end of me
i don't think i can go on
what are you doing
there we go nice and cold
[Applause]
oh boy just one question
is dirty little pig boy the other white
meat
come on spill it
well
i was just out of college i was broke
it's the oldest story in the world boy
meets girl boy wants girl to do
dominatrix film
girl says naked boy says yeah girl says
forget it boy says okay then just wear
this rubber dress and beat the old guy
with a scrub brush girl says how hard
can i see you friend
she was like dude looking right at me
hold on hold on
i just want to tell you that stan is
fine what there never was any surgery
the doctor says he only has a little
angina
wow
what a time to find out your husband's a
hermaphrodite
[Applause]
so you were just playing with us when
we're trying to help you by competing to
see who i would show my weakness to hear
when you're wrong
you played with me and you lost let that
be a lesson to you
i think you forgot kitties karen walker
doesn't do emotions
now get the hell out of here
you